what was it like for both of you reading
the scripts for the first time
for the show because it deals with a lot
of big issues while also being a halo
show um it was super
wild reading the scripts like just
reading something on paper
and then
having to imagine how that was going to
look visually was just um
i didn't know how it was gonna work um
so yeah it was it was amazing
um
i think
i
drilled into because
sometimes i can find even though i've
say this i've now done three sort of
this my third fourth sci-fi thing but i
can sometimes find them
uh inaccessible
and so i always drill into kind of what
are the themes and what it what's
where's the humanity you know where are
the big questions in this and
that excited me uh
also because the game
even throws up some of that stuff so i
knew that we'd be foraging i knew that
it wouldn't just be
battles cgi
of course there is all of that but that
there would be uh deeper questions being
asked as well
uh having any show
make it to the air is a miracle and
having any show on the air get a renewal
before it comes out is
it's very rare so for both of you what
does it mean to already know that
there's a season two and part two of
that is when do you start filming i
think i always go with the assumption
that there'll be a season two of
anything i do i get super invested in it
and
um
yeah until told otherwise that's exactly
how i set out my i mean for this
i was happy to not reveal a ton of stuff
about halsey because
i believed that i would go on for the
next few seasons to uncover and discover
and be able to reveal more about her so
i've always sort of worked on that basis
um i think we start shooting sometime
soon this summer yeah
remember there it takes a long time to
shoot so oh 100 i think i probably
opposite i operate in the complete
opposite way
i'm like there is no season two until
i'm on set like even i just i struggle
to
i just don't want to get you know
excited about anything until until it
actually happens and so it is super
exciting to to see that like yeah we've
been renewed for season two but i don't
actually think it will hit me and sink
in until i'm literally standing on set
in costume and then i'll be like huh
we're doing season two of this show yeah
which scene or sequence of season one
was the one that you read on the page
and you're like oh this is going to be
an interesting day
is there anything we can i i don't know
oh you're worried about it yeah
there's some there's some interesting
stuff coming along but i don't know if i
if any of that stuff i can say so
we'll have to see i'll tell you how we
could circumvent this
there were quite a few changes as we
were going yes
so sometimes the biggest challenge was
how can i pivot and get myself ready for
tomorrow because there's a whole new set
of things happening in a new speech
that's been written or whatever so so
sometimes those were the biggest kind of
ski jumps if you like was the unexpected
which is always fun that's why we do
what we do yeah to be surprised reacting
in the moment listen i gotta wrap
already i'm just gonna say again i
really can't wait to watch the rest of
the episodes and congrats on already
getting a season two thank you cool good
luck with the rest of your speed dating
thank you